congratulations nomination thank you
very much I think that you need to be
entertained or they get I mean I love
everybody else too but I mean it's all
good thank you well I mean I could vote
too but don't tell the others right
but unless all you need is that voter
totally absolutely no absolutely no are
you performing tonight as well what can
we expect I'm gonna do a new song it's
not a single it's just a song I heard
recently that just floored me and I yeah
and so I went in and recorded it and we
decided to do it tonight and tell me
about it it's it's this for there's a
lot of people going through some really
hard times everywhere right now and I
wanted to do a song for them and this is
for every one of them to be a special
night for you mm-hmm have you heard it
obviously yeah yeah do you think
everybody's gonna react
it did crying are you gonna cry tonight
you think me yeah I've already cried it
I'll try not to cry I'm probably gonna
cry I'm sure I am too well both crying
out there - now tell me about this
jumping out of a cake that you did what
a transition right miss Loretta Lynn
wants you to jump out of the cake you
jumping out of a cake you did quite well
it could be like a second profession
okay jumping experience or I don't know
what the etiquette is but it was such a
magical night yeah I've never seen a
lineup and so much love for somebody
like that it was beautiful yeah I was
gorgeous night yeah speaking of another
pretty night I saw that you guys went
out on a date night to see Bryan
Cranston and Broadway Network
yes the whole cast the show is just
amazing but he is a complete acting
force yeah and one of the not one of the
nicest yeah men in this working in this
industry so to see him just and he just
has boundless energy and talent mmm so
to be able to go and support that and
cheer him on and be moved talk about you
guys do this often we go see a
performance on a date night is that one
of the fun things that you like to do
we've always done it yeah yeah my
daughter's want to see gaga I imagine
you could probably get tickets I think
you know more than you yeah final thing
because I gotta let you go but
everybody's waiting and waiting
anxiously anticipating I got you the
question for big little lies okay so
tell us give me a little hint about what
we can expect when it comes down here in
a few months
well hopefully it's gonna be what
everyone hopes it's gonna be and a
little bit more right that was nothing
to call any more
I need more I mean I think it's gonna
have its own it's it has its own tone at
its own story this season which is what
we want and you really sort of follow
all of the women now in depth which is
fantastic and and it twists and turns
and but it hopefully it's very very
authentic and truthful to where these
women are life and sides of the
husband's you haven't seen to seen a few
whips
you